you have gotten yourself Jack for a role
and this photo I don't know if we have
it I think we have it it's it's been
everywhere you are just a wall of muscle
now do you feel stronger do you actually
feel like superhero strong no these
muscles are decorative they don't do
anything you really don't
Emily will do that can you open this jar
for me I'm like probably not now how did
fans respond when you revealed ID Kumail
Nanjiani now have this physique people
expect me to be different and I'm really
not I'm just like I am slightly less
interesting because I do talk about
working out a lot yeah
and I'm slightly less funny right other
than that no big guy same guy same guy
do people get intimidated by you now no
cuz of my voice one guy was like I wish
his voice would get a six-pack you you
are honored that they put you at pornhub
puts you in the muscular man category
they did you were and this is a true
story you were in the pornhub muscular
men catwalk under the category yeah it
was mature milk and then muscular man
and it was a picture of me and they gave
me a ten year free subscription to
pornhub premium
[Applause]
you know Kai just say I love the way the
crowd reacted to that okay they reacted
as if you had been terminally ill and
then suddenly you announce you're cured
and it was about a 10-year subscription
I will say you know cuz people are like
why do you need to pay for poor and I
don't I do not work for pornhub they
have not paid me to say this right but
Andy does Andy furious right now a
three-year premium subscription I'll
share my login with you you just have to
coordinate are you free Thursday I'll be
like I'll text you like hey stay off it
for the next five to seven minutes
awaits oh it's so you have access to a
whole new world like free porn is good
but when you go to premium I could
develop fetishes crazy ones over the
next ten years and I know I'll be taken
care of right there's a lot I have no
idea like what's happening on front
Premium porn while I have to explain it
to you yeah wouldn't I just picture the
same stuffs happening but they're all
wearing like really nice hat slightly
more petty this is nice you got input it
is nice yep not that Oh this next thing
I was gonna say you were invited to join
was at times a hundred most influential
people's list yeah I was weren't you
also asked to join the Academy yeah I'm
the movie academy the movie Academy
which was great and the time thing which
was great they pick a hundred people
every year and again people were upset
they were like Camaro set that you're in
there
they were like Kamil's on the list and
Vladimir Putin isn't on the list I'm
like I don't want to piss him off
it should be him not me yeah I'm a fan
if you know what that is are put that is
our Putin camera by the way the one that
goes right to him
great work man yeah keep at it
have a fan so yeah well we're people
like people you said that people were
upset that like hey if you're on a list
I would think it makes sense because the
minute you're on a list there are people
that are angry well why you and not that
other person yeah cuz there's always
honestly I agree with the my I should
not be on I don't agree I think you
should be on the list
thank you I think you're right I'm not
just saying it to me you're a very
influential you are you've got a big
following you but uh you know you know a
big part of the community I'm just
throwing out words you're really like
yes
bottom of the barrel there you're a big
part of the community a human being yeah
you're a person you have a you inhabit
earth you have parents that care about
you know I'm you've had a very
successful career and I think you should
be one of the bank you I just realized
my parents are gonna watch this and know
that I have a ten year subscription to
pornhub pretty much I guess it dad's
gonna visit now
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry mr.
Nanjiani but it's a known fact I wish
you could have seen what I saw was just
like two feet away couldn't going dad's
gonna visit now and then eyebrows bitter
fig that was the creepiest thing I've
ever eaten
dad's gonna visit you know maybe you
were right to cancel last the doors it's
also nice to that now he has a reason
yeah to visit you or anything but like
what he's got poor man whatever work
yeah yeah I miss him
let's talk about free porn what's all
about let's talk about little America I
think it's an amazing project and I'm
very excited for you you were the
executive producer of this show little
America and this is I guess your effort
project to get people to relate to the
immigrant struggle with that's a tough
Segway pulled off very well from or to
the lives of immigrants hey everybody
there are immigrants that have gotten
their start in foreign
you went back you went back and tried
off the bridge went back and jumped off
hydrant right it's a job I tried to pay
that job that is true it is a job right
yes
yeah and it's if they work hard
immigrants do too I don't think this
show will air okay strong feeling that
none of this will air that they're going
to show a farm report from 1980s from
Iowa this or the like what's weaker
bench for to get on you for not showing
up last time yeah here we go well okay
so little America is the show it's an
anthology show so every episode is
completely different and they're based
on real stories of immigrants to America
and the dramatized versions you know
they're like actors and we wrote them
and change the story a little bit but
yeah all eight of them are completely
different completely different towns
there's you know people from Syria
Mexico it's like all over the world Iran
India and just very very proud of the
show it's it's on Apple TV plus I think
you know I have many times just living
in him you can live in any city in the
United States and experiences but in Los
Angeles when I encounter people who have
come here three four years ago some of
them not speaking the language and
they're reinventing their lives they're
reinventing who they are in this foreign
country I'm so blown away and when I
talk to them I think I don't know that I
I don't know that I could do that I grew
up here and I'm the Bennet I'm the
beneficiary of so many events and these
you hear about these people and it is
that's why I think this project is such
a great idea and you know I've spoken to
so many people you meet somebody like I
was talking to this old gentleman and he
was a chemist where he was from and now
he was driving a cab you know so I think
a lot of immigrants when they move you
sort of take a hit so that the next
generation can have the life that they
want for their children so yeah it's a
it's a tough thing coming to a place
where you might not
speak the language and where your
identity is not as valued you know I
feel like it's sort of a tricky time for
immigrants in America did you have how
old were you when you I was 18 you were
18 yeah that's so very I mean that
that's a very young formative age to
come here that must have been tricky
yeah it was but again you know I was
very lucky in that my experience was I
came for college so I was in a bubble I
was cushioned do you know and so my
experience was not as as difficult as it
could have been so I feel I feel very
grateful but yeah so these all these
these stories are I find them very
inspirational you know and I think the I
feel you know I've always felt there are
the people who sort of have it's a
divisive issue obviously the issue of
immigration and I feel like those people
who are anti-immigration I I'm like you
were born here these people chose to
come here they fought to be here in a
way you know they're more American I'm
the most American man here is what I'm
saying this is really sound like well
we're out of time
Andy's from Switzerland that's right I'm
all cheese
[Laughter]